Between 1947 and 1956 a collection of ancient Jewish texts was found in a
series of caves along the Dead Sea. These 972 texts are known as the Dead Sea
Scrolls. And they had a huge impact on history, linguistics and religious
studies. Of course, reading the content of these texts was very important, but
estimating their age was also really vital. The way that that was done was
through carbon dating. So, what is carbon dating? Well, it's a technique used
to find the age of any organic material that's up to 58,000 years old. This is
done by considering the ratio of carbon 14 to carbon 12 in the material. Now if
you're not super comfortable with chemistry, that is not a big deal at all. I'm
going to give you all the information you need in this problem to figure
everything out. You don't have to be an expert on carbon dating. What happens
is that over time the amount of carbon 12 stays pretty constant. But the amount
of carbon 14 decreases. These atoms decay. So the older something is, the
smaller this ratio will be. One scrap of parchment from the Dead Sea Scrolls
was found to have a ratio of carbon 14 to carbon 12, 0.795 times that found in
plants alive today. Now, if this ratio for plants alive today, is 1 atom of
carbon 14 for every 10 to the 12 atoms of carbon 12, what is the same ratio for
the parchment?